bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 4 de agosto se cumplen 60 años de
la muerte de una de las mayores
estrellas que ha dado hollywood en su
historia marilyn monroe seis décadas que
sin embargo no han servido para apagar
la luz de su figura como la de una de
los iconos más representativos de la
cultura popular del siglo 20 en france
24 repasamos su vida su legado y su
polémico fallecimiento que hasta el día
de hoy sigue levantando toda clase de
teorías
marilyn monroe nació en 1926 con el
nombre de norma jeane mortenson su
infancia estuvo marcada por el abandono
de sus padres y por su periplo por
varias familias de acogida y orfanatos
unos años en los que llegó a sufrir
abusos sexuales con la llegada de su
juventud destacaron sus dotes artísticas
y su belleza algo que hizo que se
fijarán en ella
durante sus primeros años monroe se
empeñó en triunfar como actriz e
invirtió gran parte de su tiempo en
mejorar sus capacidades de actuación y
cantó a pesar de que en un principio
sólo obtuvo pequeños trabajos y que
algunos productores aseguraron que no
servía para triunfar en hollywood monroe
fue haciéndose un espacio en la
industria y fue conociendo a gente del
mundo del cine que hicieron que pudiera
promocionarse como actriz a través de la
gran pantalla
los papeles que llevaron al éxito a
monroe fueron en comedias estas
películas se centraban en destacar su
atractivo físico e hicieron que la
actriz se convirtiera en un icono sexual
de su época
sus películas resultaron las más
taquilleras del momento llegando a
alcanzar los 200 millones de dólares de
ganancias una cantidad comparable a dos
mil millones de dólares en la actualidad
pero monroe dejó en claro desde el
inicio que no pretendía encasillarse en
el papel de icono sexual al querer
protagonizar películas de otro tipo
su obsesión era mejorar como actriz
desde mediados de la década de los 50
monroe comenzó a intercambiar su
aparición en comedias con películas de
cine negro títulos como niágara the
seven year itch o bass stop dispararon
su reputación en la gran pantalla un
reconocimiento que le llegaría en forma
de premio en 1959 cuando obtuvo el globo
de oro a la mejor actriz por su papel en
some like it hot
sin embargo más allá de su éxito
profesional la vida de marilyn monroe
fuera de las pantallas siempre estuvo en
el centro de la atención del público
la actriz fue protagonista de varias
polémicas como su desnudo en el primer
número de la revista playboy además sus
mediáticos matrimonios y posteriores
divorcios con el beisbolista joe
dimaggio y el guionista arthur miller
ocuparon las portadas durante años
el matrimonio con joe dimaggio apenas
dura dos años ya que marilyn llegó a
sufrir malos tratos por parte de su
esposo algo muy diferente al periodo que
estuvo con arthur miller entre 1956 y
1961 en esta etapa alcanzó su cénit
profesional y su mayor estabilidad
personal sin embargo una serie de
abortos hicieron que su salud
psicológica empeorará al igual que su
adicción a los barbitúricos unos
medicamentos que actúan como sedantes
del sistema nervioso central y que son
recetados usualmente para tratar la
ansiedad
marilyn arrastró durante su vida adulta
problemas psicológicos derivados de su
convulsa infancia una cuestión que se
acentuó todavía más con la presión
mediática y el hecho de que se
convirtiera en una estrella esta
situación hizo que desde mediados de los
cincuenta comenzará a ser adicta a los
barbitúricos mezclados con alcohol una
combinación que empeoraría su salud
pero sus momentos más convulsos vendrían
con la llegada de la década de 1960 tras
divorciarse de arthur miller en 1961
monroe fue señalada como amante de dos
de las figuras políticas más importantes
de eeuu el ex presidente john fitzgerald
kennedy y su hermano robert kennedy una
cuestión que levantó la polémica y que
se trató de ocultar desde la casa blanca
pero que muchos testigos aseguran que
sus encuentros eran habituales para la
historia quedará la canción de
cumpleaños que marilyn cantó en directo
al presidente kennedy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y por qué
es a partir de su relación con los dos
hermanos kennedy cuando comienzan a
resonar todo tipo de rumores sobre su
muerte
marilyn monroe murió en su cama el 4 de
agosto de 1962 después de haber
consumido una cantidad de barbitúricos
muy alta los forenses apuntaron a un
suicidio sin embargo con el paso de los
años los rumores e investigaciones que
apuntaban a un asesinato por su relación
con los kennedy y su militancia de
izquierdas en un contexto de guerra fría
comenzaron a tomar fuerza al igual que
los relatos de testigos que negaban la
versión oficial una cuestión que ha
hecho que se escriban decenas de libros
y que incluso en el año 1982 se
reabriera su caso para investigar un
posible asesinato
no nunca dije que ella fue asesinada
dije que hay bastantes motivos para que
haya sido asesinada ayer se diría que
fueron una parte de miembros derechista
del fbi y la cia pero es simplemente mi
opinión porque no hay evidencia de
comprobar lo que digo es sólo mi opinión
sea como fuere la imagen de marilyn
monroe siguió estando muy viva entre el
imaginario popular que más allá de su
carrera artística o su atractivo físico
uno de los iconos de la cultura popular
más representativos del siglo 20 con
esto concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]